hello hey welcome welcome to big moon
the thing that is happening it is
happening and it happened so fast
welcome 20:20 yeah it's a new mood it's
a new us so we changed our set and it is
moody in here and we thought because
we're doing a new show we would start by
not introducing ourselves cuz you guys
already know who we are and if you
haven't you could look at some of our
earlier videos but kind of talk about
our group dynamic because we all pretty
much bonded through a group chat and
it's interesting because each one of us
I feel like have really specific
personalities and branding and it's like
very clear and each person kind of
brings like a different mood out of you
so I think it's very fitting to the name
of the show yeah so but I don't know
like what people would think of me oh
yeah bribe III can't describe like Who I
am in this group but I know that you
know everyone else can like for me and
then vice versa so yeah I never had this
discussion before ever I've had this you
guys are seeing this discussion for the
first time I didn't know to rate your
friends radio reading each other the
first time I said it to rate and I'm
like but we're actually reading each
other just get to 9 yes thanks we're
labeling each other's what we're doing
is we're stereotyping each other you
guys ever taken an acting class like
where they do an image portion no okay
ooh so all of you at home you could do
this too you could do it with your
friends family the public but it's
really interesting to see what you get
back because a lot of times we don't
know how other people see you so Gary
typing yeah yeah like like typecasting
or that's the word yeah like in the
industry Hollywood it's called
podcasting yeah if you're not getting
typecast you're not getting cast okay so
like Spice Girls except for a big mood
like usually in like an exercise someone
will sit in the middle so if we had the
spotlight on tip you don't actually sit
in the middle but we would start she
would just sit there quietly and we
would start like shouting out different
adjectives and like phrases Oh imagine
imagine Easter's you could see her
playing imagine like I sit in the middle
and someone in the back yells horn like
little [ __ ] at that waitress
yeah like waitress at an airport
waitress at a barbecue spot yeah Texas
that's why you're not wrong but I don't
like it
what's really fun about that too though
is like I didn't like some of the
adjectives that were thrown out in that
class but then you kind of start to own
them and using a lot of adjectives have
a simile that's more positive like
sometimes a word will affect you because
you have a negative association with it
like one girl got ambitious in the class
and she got pissed she was actually a
life coach um but because they're you
I'm lazy [ __ ] you for the word ambitious
meant that she steps on peoples
opportunistic and so she just had a word
maybe she needs to learn how to read the
dictionary and look up definitions you
should learn how to read illiterate
[Laughter]
vacation you're the most are you seeing
this beautiful tan my god they made me
sit next to the hot tan girl thing and
you know I'm gonna take that's my word
for too hot okay
the hot white girl I'm on the milk mood
right now I don't know buddy
guys Jamie moon so I would love if we
like gave tip all the adjectives that
she just like looks like or like her
presence and then we tell you what she's
really like in the chat okay I already
got like two words for it okay but we'll
do you want to start talking no I don't
care what okay so are you like we're
physically but it's still like a
personality thing all the word I would
give you is like bubbly Oh like I think
that's how people probably like it like
that's how I would see you know I'd be
like oh she's bubbly wait do I go to my
like other word of like yes or do we you
know knows always just shirt shouting
things at her debatable oh by looks
right vibe okay cuz I already know her
yeah okay all adjectives work change of
the rules as we go I would I say like
Monica from friends oh yeah organized
yes okay I like determined like you you
you are like if there's a problem if is
like okay here it is I don't know what
to do right now but I want to figure it
out help me figure it out all right and
I and then I'll do it and I'll figure it
out and I'm going and it's I don't know
like I can't really describe it but like
you when when you encounter a roadblock
you lay out everything and you're like
alright let's let's let's do this yeah
you solve problems yeah really yeah
that's so cool yeah yeah I'm also like
lately there's been a huge shift in you
so like maybe six months of you ago I
wouldn't have said the same adjectives
but lately you've been like glowing and
yeah I feel like you're just like a ball
of light Phoenix
yeah it's been like a renaissance for
TIFF rebirth she came out fierce and tan
amazing lately thank you
what kind of show would you cast if on
ooh like what character would she be
yeah with like typecast character I
still see her in high school
yeah very useful for sure
I would say the encouraging best friend
yeah I was over when the main character
is going through a breakup she's like I
got you girl and she like wrote a list
out of things like to do to make you
feel better I think she's like the
ride-or-die she's like you're she's like
the girl that's your neighbor and lives
next door and like when something's
going on you're like you already do and
she's like oh yeah I'll come right over
and just [ __ ] climbs up to your
window like girl next door yeah yeah
like like best pal like yeah that's kind
of like how I see you
balancing a chat she's nothing like that
she is just a darker before as I'm just
kidding oh she has a dark side to her
what she doesn't like she's a dark humor
like when she doesn't like someone she's
like no burn them she does the funniest
gifs well she oh my god oh my god guys
okay so this is Tiff's dynamic in the
chat and all of us will be talking and
like tip is like always busy she's with
eyes she's a mom yeah like she's out
there killing it and so maybe like an
hour and end to the conversation she'll
pop in and then she'll just like send a
gift just like a reaction and it's so
funny yes the timing is perfect
so imagine your friend that's like
always there and then she comes in she's
like what's going on like sometimes when
it's during like a heated time like we
were like all like firing shots and
stuff like you come in and you're just
like a that window service all my
responses weren't coming through but
then that one's like Conan O'Brien at
one point he's like looking through the
window that's kind of fitting then if
you were trying to send messages it's
like you're trying to talk to everybody
that's true crack me up more than
anything
so if she was a Spice Girl whoo which
spice posh spice yeah because she's
always wearing like really nice clothes
she's like the perfect family got
married in Paris yeah earrings on to
like nice earrings just a chic taste she
always looks rich we went to a party so
we both have this like Beverly Hills
dentist and we went to this this like
event and she had nails perfect like a
little like glittery but not tacky like
cute knit like rings earrings hair
looked sleek outfit looked amazing like
she was accessorized perfectly like
shilling like one of them [ __ ] to
take care of herself
yeah and then I showed up in a
sweatshirt that said Virginia without my
even with a ponytail and when we go to
their like there's this rooftop party
and stuff and then they're like oh let's
get a picture with TIFF and I was like
doctor doctor manis my dentist different
mix of people like there's such a
different personality for each person I
like that you're so Posh Spice yeah
that's awesome
David what do you guys think use your
own name - it doesn't have to be like
the actual Spice Girls names oh yeah
like you know how we have that one group
shower or like sad spy we fight over
daddy mommy issues I know that oh my god
emotional sugar spice oh I'm financially
responsible spice all the time for no
reason spice Gina didn't sleep last
night by the way and she's still here so
let's give her a round
[Applause]
she was the first one here and she
showed up fully done and yeah we got
here yes miss Gina did not exist like
what four five years ago that's so true
yeah he's like a vision yeah I walked in
and Gina was waiting on us fully dressed
makeup on almost like oh my god is it
new wait we're gonna do me yeah yeah
we're gonna do you know wait wait before
we move on to test I just want to hear
what do you think of yourself - um let
me see what I think about myself I think
I am a very honest loyal I can be happy
if things are right I guess I'm Moody I
think I would consider mu I think you
have like certain things that like you
get annoyed with like I wouldn't say you
fully like I get offended so moods yeah
at home it does oh and with something
you feel like misunderstood about like
something that a lot of people think you
are but you're not honest with it's
public-facing yeah damn I don't know I
never really thought about this oh I
think well this is like a lot of nice
from what I've seen people think that
you're very um like roll with the
punches and just take it yeah but as of
lately no oh no enough for yourself no I
think I've found my voice or I'm finding
my voice to the point where now I'm like
no yeah I want to say this or I want to
do this and like yeah I think I help I
always have been that way just really go
with the flow and I'm just like okay
yeah sure whatever's but now I'm like no
no this is my life I like that and
you're 30 recently turned 30 yeah and I
feel like one of us
[Laughter]
holding it down in the 20s for us is the
time by the time you hit 30 is when you
really get to like find your yeah you
like know yourself I can definitely say
yes yes yeah I totally have felt like I
found myself cuz all these questions
you're asking me like I've never been
very introspective where I actually
analyzed like Who I am what do I think
what I like what I don't like or I don't
know I've always just been like oh yeah
like oh people pleaser not really
understanding what I want and like Who I
am but especially recently I've really
felt like I've been like ahead of my
cage and like I could finally be free
and like figure myself out and just like
how my spirit animal quiz and it labeled
me as a butterfly and like I feel like
I'm a young butterfly now like I feel
free that's awesome I picture your wings
just continuously changing colors
alright like I don't know what to do
with my body and they were like hey buzz
come over here and make big just laughs
and I just walked in when I was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] whenever she's like
whenever she's trying to like think
about so when she's candid you're like
perfect like awesome but then like when
you try like yeah you have like a still
like a little bit of a guard but it's
coming down a lot like yeah especially
both of you like in the past six months
I've just like flipped a switch you're
just like yeah killing it now word it's
like oh well I think it's also like the
show too because like and you guys you
guys have given us literally a [ __ ]
business like we we are we are like all
partners we feel empowered like and and
we're like where do we want to take this
what do we want to do like we want to
share with the world and it kind of
helps us explore ourselves more you know
my word for just as of lately especially
what's been going on the chat
vixen oh I don't know about that I'm
covering up some marks on my body
Jess asan stew girls did you guys
remember in Halloween when she was
sitting at the restaurant away from us
in her in her devil costume these guys
were on her and I was like what blue
eyes all red with the red lips it goes
like that I was wearing that like on
purpose like it was it like an outfit
cuz I took the horns off like they
thought I was just wearing like I was
just out on a Tuesday night and the
whole like don't matter whether they
thought it was a costume or not they
liked you just weren't ready you weren't
like I wonder you're open you didn't
have you're open to people flirting with
you yeah oh yeah I was just like just a
costume go away
no stop staring at me what Dan we were
too out yeah I have a word for Jess I
think the audience knows this okay do it
I don't know if you're even gonna love
it okay the hide fight it's like like my
word for jess is whistleblower Oh
like if something if something is wrong
Jess is not afraid to be like hey what
it what is this yeah like you like it or
not pick this up like do this but and I
mean it's like it's always for the best
it she's never wrong about it either
like I'm always always always a hundred
temperance I see some [ __ ] I go
analyze little [ __ ]
I was gonna say like very rational but
that to be more specific
no sometimes like well it is rational
but I don't always present it like in
the best maybe most tactful way I'll
just be like yeah and everyone's like
wait what's going on and then like when
the dust settles people are like oh my
god right yeah in a beer can yes that is
your analogy what does that mean your
metaphor well I was gonna say you know
like whiskey and a teacup is common like
if you're almost kind of proper but then
like inside they're like we run wild but
it just is like whiskey and a beer can
yeah my word would be fierce fierce like
even like if I didn't know you and I'm
just judging you based off of looks I
would think you're a [ __ ] model while
she just accept it yeah I guess I can't
be that fierce if I don't accept it
right but even without accepting it like
your face already well I do have a very
angry face you're very blunt yes I will
say that yeah what a bluntness yeah
which I like I like blunt people yeah so
I like I like blunt people - I like
sarcasm I like when we could kind of
fight but it's not real yes you're not
upset about it I would say transparent
yeah you're always gonna know how I feel
about you right yeah I would hide
anything
yeah finesse anything yeah but sometimes
that works against me because like we
have business relationships with like
people I'm like bones can you handle
this relationship with our ad agency or
like some other is like a back piece not
the mouth oh I'll help guide us but
someone else needs to be in front yeah
you know what's crazy
hmm how soft Nicky's breasts look oh
yeah oh I am wearing a third love bra
which is why King love a third love it
because one they do a style quiz
at home how is it hello you're like
you're not even wearing a bra right yeah
super comfy Wow what I love about their
bras is that you take a specific quiz
for your fit and everything and a lot of
people don't know that they're wearing a
bra that doesn't really fit them I
really didn't know that I had been
wearing a bra where the cups had a gap
in it for a year I was thinking that's
how bras are I didn't think that there
could be a bra that fit you correctly
and so you take a style quiz they even
have like half sizes they have plus
sizes they have all a huge range of
sizes and they based off what you say
your current profits they will size you
with the perfect bra and what I love is
that there's not a lot of padding and
it's not a love that you know what I
love the most about third love is that
you know the bras like on the outer edge
it always like curls some yeah
especially after you wash them and it's
just like not good quality I freaking
love I'm I'm telling I'm really I'm
wearing it right now and I love it back
that I'd prove it
Rubin I tried I tried I saw it and I saw
a little nip the audience to feel doing
and I like that the wire doesn't so the
strap wraps don't slip off yeah and
there's no oh you know that back fat
thing yeah dude I hate that and this
does not give you that this completely
seamless under your shirt so I freaking
love it you should definitely take the
fit finder quiz and identify your breast
size and shape and find styles that fit
your personal body every customer has 60
days to wear it wash it and put it to
the test and if you don't love it you
can return it and third-level wash it
and donate it to a woman in need which
is nice oh it's hands-down the most
comfortable roll you'll you'll ever own
I totally agree with that so do i and
they donate all their gently-used return
bras to women in need we talked about
that so third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering our listeners 15% off
your first order go to 3rd love comm /
big mood
oh yeah we could say our name the
sponsors don't hate us okay find your
perfect fitting bra get 15% off your
purchase that's third love.com slash big
mood for 15% off today yes also in the
realm of women and beauty we have
function of beauty my favorite shampoo
and conditioner I was using this really
expensive one because I dyed my hair
blonde and everyone was like use this
brand you have to use this brand so I
started using that brand but then once I
start using function of beauty my hair
actually got much softer even though
it's bleached it's pretty wrecked but
the conditioner that I got from function
of beauty is amazing the purple shampoo
am using is amazing I left my zit to
give you the bottle with your name
printed on it and you get to pick which
colors and they want yeah and yeah
love's customized [ __ ] like it says my
name on the bottle a key function of
Gina yeah and so what I also like they
address all your hair needs not just one
so like when you take this little quiz
like you you let them know like oh my
hair is brittle but also it's colored
and also it's this and that a lot of
stuff at the grocery store it's just
like volume or whatever you know this is
addressing multiple issues which I love
so let's see what else we got here I
suggest the peach one by the way yeah
it's real gauge don't taste it never
uses sulfates parabens phthalates
mineral oils or any other harmful
ingredients 100% vegan and cruelty-free
so let's give that stuff a try there
listeners will receive 20% off their
first shampoo and conditioner set to
redeem head to function in beauty calm /
big and take the hair quiz ships to the
US and many locations worldwide again go
to function of beauty calm / big mood to
get 20% off your custom formula all
right back to roasting Jessica oh gosh
yeah [ __ ] didn't I get enough of this
roasting time I don't even
love you just medium-rare right now and
we want to give you guys can roast me
harder if you want one thing that I love
is that because we've talked about this
before that like roasting I grew up in a
family that we all just like roasted
each other we busted balls and that's
like every guy I've ever dated we bust
each other's balls yeah and so people I
get along with really well or like
people that like can bust balls back
sometimes I accidentally say something
and people don't take and I'm like oh
[ __ ] you're not oh you're not one of I'm
sorry I has always corrected that yeah
yeah it's it with tip she's like to me I
didn't grow up that way yeah I don't
like Gina I've never but you know which
ones you can be like shut up you stinky
[ __ ] like I'm just like roasts
everyone and we're like excuse that like
I love that about you especially to like
I know we're not on your turn yet but
like definitely the roasting thing I
wish girls could roast each other a lot
more because to me that's fine I roast
all the guys that I know I roast all the
girls that I know if I can yeah that's
me happy I feel like it's like how you
grew up probably like yeah I mean I grew
up as a single child but I think I hung
around boys a lot yes so it was very
much a tomboy and I still am pretty
tomboyish
so yeah the definitely guys are easier
together that way it liked about this
group too is that I never really had a
group of girlfriends I was always like a
group of guy friends yeah where I was in
a relationship and I always like hung
out with that guy friend and then maybe
one girlfriend at a time but this is
like so refreshing and nice and anyway
back to [ __ ] Jess this [ __ ] yeah I
got it I got it I'm slick because I got
it off of me you know I would also say
like humble I think you're very to a
fault sometimes like yeah yeah
and you look like a goddamn model and
you're just like none I your you're
crazy and I think just [ __ ] take it
dude I went shopping with Jess once and
then like I'm I'm objectifying her I'm
trying to put her in as much [ __ ] that
makes her a sixth at yeah right and I
love it right but she's like no it makes
my thighs a weird like [ __ ] this looks
amazing yeah yeah like I picked out
everything pair of pants I probably like
I possibly like oh my god I look like
sausage it's like that one scene when in
white chicks where he's like trying
things on in front of that girl and then
she's like he was like damn that looks
amazing she's like what is just like in
the group chat I think I feel like I'm
available I'm always I think me and Bo's
maybe are the only people that don't
have it muted everyone else has it on
like yeah or something I'll just check
it later but the chat is always working
running with me yeah because sometimes
the check is so lit and like I find that
I leave you [ __ ] alone for a minute
and I come back and I'm like yeah like
sometimes we do out to put the chat on
Do Not Disturb like if Nikki's like
shooting or something they're sleeping
usually if we hit up Gina and the chat
it's like oh she's not gonna read this
until like 5 p.m. yeah that's when I pop
in like hey guys here says anything like
Jess and I are like yeah well first
responders
[Laughter]
because like when I was shopping I like
okay so I took a picture for like things
that I wanted to buy for our photo shoot
that we did and immediately just was
like like I didn't even finish today do
you want this and I'm like oh yeah sure
she's already left me she had a home
cookin dinner yeah well what's the thing
that people misunderstand about you what
you people misunderstand about me I mean
I think like um I would say clans I feel
like people like when I like back when I
was dating Joe or whatever especially
towards the end and like last year I
think a lot of people always like she's
always just so unhappy and I remember
feeling like but that's really not who I
am that's just like what I'm happy I
think I happen to be showing like when
I'm on camera sometimes and I hated that
yeah I think that too because like they
take your critical demeanour as being
like unhappy or [ __ ] yeah when really
you're not saying anything unhappy or
[ __ ] I mean I have a [ __ ] face not RBF
give them a good RBF beat my ass I'm
just oh no I think um like so things
either just excite me or they don't and
like other people might like kind of
feign a little bit of excitement because
the other person is excited or something
like that and I've just never like been
a like people pleaser types um always
just like okay whatever you know well as
maybe Gina or something she'd be like oh
my god it's so cute like it for you you
know like she like kind of make you feel
good about yourself too and I'm just
like I don't give a [ __ ] like feeling
yeah so like I think I'm getting better
at that now but I think a lot of people
read that I was like I'm just unhappy
but I think a lot of times too I'm just
like not I don't get it I just don't
react that much stuff but I'm trying to
get a little better at that I actually
related to you a lot with that when I
first met you because
before like when I first started acting
and all that stuff I was very like very
much like that like super monotone and I
was I would always just like tell people
what I thought but I wouldn't like how
these colorful voices in my and my you
know and I wasn't sing-songy or anything
and I had to like work with my acting
coach and voice coach to like insert
those colors because in auditions they
were going flat like it was coming out
flat even though I felt inside that I
was expressing happiness or like anger
or whatever it was just coming out
that's me because I feel like I try so
hard on camera and then I watch it back
and I'm like wow it's still flat but I'm
like that took a lot out of me to like
me so I'm like I thought I was emoting
and I'm not girl I feel you sometimes
when they're like when I was working
with the coaches maybe like do it like
this and I felt like it was so big yeah
but then I saw it on camera it's really
not just like a normal human
[Laughter]
yeah all right cool that's just to let
us know in the comments what your first
reactions of Jess I mean what the place
over time oh yeah sporty spice labels
grabbed it works out I want to call you
ginger true
you think I'm what sex pot in the group
give you road head she was yeah you are
ginger in the club head at the back of a
54 Ford yeah yeah with like her toes
[Laughter]
like resting [ __ ] face is like she's
like [ __ ] you you [ __ ] get out of here
finish up and get out of your hair get
the show on the road pose
I always see bows in a suit in my head
like Tom Ford pink heels on she wants
you to dress up because bows will come
in like y'all I got this contact with
this and we're making this we're doing
that yeah oh my god this like bows is in
a constant she's like this that's so
funny because it switches between that
and like you with a ski mask and a
baseball bat I'm not kidding we never
had this conversation
scary yeah whenever like boos just she's
like she gets it done dude it's amazing
to me she comes out with graphs and like
Excel sheets
yeah she's connected to everyone at a
laptop that comes out of nowhere you're
like where the [ __ ] are saying words
like SEO and I'm like advertising the
business woman but she also lays in bed
with me and we read it silently Tina and
I we can like not talk to each other for
hours and then like the first thing
we'll say to each other after two hours
we'll be like uh do you want to put your
order in the best roommate ever
whenever we room together it's it's
great yeah it's great really I can see
that like on a show you would be like a
roommate character that just comes in
like all right here's what we're gonna
do caretaker - I was here in this [ __ ]
brought everything
I needed in giant stacked boots I'm like
you know what yeah I love her yeah I
would say Bose you're a big ball of
energy like static energy anytime you
come around I'm always like oh I'm ready
cuz you make it fun like you're your
personality you just come with a lot of
excitement and like just like the whole
like business thing to like you approach
it in a very exciting way where it's
like I want to be business girl to like
I want to join on your level because
you're getting [ __ ] done and I feel
[ __ ] lazy but like whenever you're
like hell yeah buzz is motivating the
[ __ ] out of me she is cocaine in human
form she's both though she has another
side he's gonna say like I've been told
before people be like oh you you light
up a room or like your energy is really
big but and you know for anyone else
that is kind of like that I don't know
what it is it's like an aura that you
put out but you have to be in tune with
that because also when you're down you
put that mood into the room - yeah and
like I know sometimes if I'm not in a
great spot like I or if I'm like in a
really low spot like I can bring the
energy like a down you could like suck
the whole energy out kind of like a
dying star but I mean like it's
something it's something you have to and
I'd say this because I feel like there's
other people I got to but it's something
you have to just accept is about you and
when you're not in the best spot you
gotta like at least try to be stoic like
you know what I love about you though is
that even though when you know you're in
that that mood or like that's what
you're feeling you put it out there and
you make it be known so like no one ever
like misinterprets what you're what
you're doing like for example when we
went out one time and you were just like
hey just let you know because we were
gonna jump on an uber and you're like
just let you know right now and put it
on my my earphones I need a recharge so
don't talk to me and I'm like a great
night laughing talking blah blah we
called it over and I pulled my head I
was like by the way guys don't talk to
me for five minutes I was like I'm fine
and I'm gonna be even better when
everyone leaves me alone for a minute
and then the car ride
because I always feel like doing that
and then I'd like scared of what people
would think of that I want to keep like
partying I want to be out yeah it's like
she respects herself so much and it like
forces us to it's like she's telling it
how it is
so we're just going to take it that's
the blunt Jean that I really like yeah I
love like just straightforwardness like
that you're like um so you're like a in
my head like a picture like a tornado
that changes colors where it's like
right in glittery and then if you like
[Laughter]
you are you're like I don't have to be
like okay and oh my god
[Laughter]
well poses nipples are lighter than all
of ours
no you said it all like you're lying
yeah we'd never seen a black girl
opinion yeah with that deep fake yeah
y'all could try but there's a white in
there somewhere
I was thinking like baby spice for you I
could see sporty spice though for sure I
always an athletic wear yeah that a lot
of yeah for sure
so what's something that you feel
misunderstood about that people always
peg us but it's not true
a lot of people say that like I am very
high-energy and I don't feel I know III
just I don't feel like I'm a very
high-energy okay well you're technically
it's amazing thank you beacon did you
know that is clear aligners yes I didn't
know because I can't even see them oh
thank you thank you
do you have straight natural white
beautiful perfect teeth like me no I
don't want to mess up girl I've seen it
how do I get those straight teeth well
Gina I'll tell you there's a company
called candid and I recommend you check
it out because it's 65% less than braces
cost wise financially on your wallet and
braces are hella expensive and they're
not cubed they're not cute oh they're
not clear even if you get the clear
bands like I had to do they turn yellow
and it's not yellow rings around metal
don't want it stuck all up in them oh
yeah ain't about it it's a mess yes so
you need some candid girls and you get
it and then you spray-paint it gold so
hope it really tell me the truth well
unlike races candy clear aligners are
comfortable removable and totally
invisible so you never you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing any
of that garbage that you got going on
they also work with actual orthodontists
not
general dentist so you know you're gonna
get a really good plan for your teeth
set up they are an expert in tooth
movement with 20 years of experience on
average so looking ahead to the holidays
to any special events weddings whatever
you got that you have to smile in and
you don't want to have that gap-toothed
or you don't have that cricket teeth you
could get straight teeth in like six
weeks six months sorry six months
imagine you have a girlfriend and she
has a messed up imagine but you still
love her so this is like a nice way to
give her a Christmas present
I mean you could try that you heard
right to your door to well you see never
have to step foot in a doctor's office
so she's like wow how convenient what a
good boyfriend or girlfriend that you
are they gave that gave me these nice
set of teeth yep you would learn more
about candids process by getting a
complimentary 3d scan of your teeth at
candid I had a candid studio near you
it's the simplest freest way to get
started how exciting yeah code well so
if you're ready to take the first step
towards straighter teeth for a limited
time you can get started with $75 off by
using five eighty five dollars three
quarters of the way to 100 the code is
candid co.com slash mood are you ready
to get some straight as teeth I hate my
teeth all right well for a limited time
you can get started with $75 off whoa by
using code mood at candid co.com slash
mood and it co.com slash mood and then
use the code mood candy coat calm /mu
clothes code mood what do you want and
with those nice looking teeth you could
also eat some really nice-looking oh yes
you can I haven't it is delightful oh my
god more about it though you know they
have a couple of different packages they
have like you can do
or you can do four different meals per
week it depends what your needs are for
me personally I work a really busy
nine-to-five and a lot of times out of
the week I have to go out for business
dinners or seeing friends and I don't
really know when it's gonna be so I get
three meals a week I cooked and it's
usually two-person meals I cook one it's
my dinner that night and my lunch for
work the next day and it just works out
boom boom boom all through the week like
I love it and there's like step-to-step
recipes which are super easy to make
even from beginners there's everything's
pre-measured everything's super what is
it fresh yeah like everything like
thirty minutes so it makes you look like
a pro and there's a photo on it too you
can please imagine everything to make it
look good
also there are different types of food
that you can do there's a family meal
there's vegetarian interion one
hellofresh has more five-star recipes
and any other meal kits so you know
you'll be getting something delicious
you can also add extra meals to your
weekly order because they're super
flexible as well as an ons like garlic
and cookie dough oh I saw that that
stuff is new and it's amazing yeah you
can easily change your delivery days if
you want to food preferences and skip a
week whenever you need so if you're like
Nikki going on vacation soon put a pause
on it so you guys can get 9 free meals
with hellofresh
by going to hellofresh comm /u and using
code big mood 9 again get nine week free
meals with hellofresh by going to
hellofresh comm slash big mood 9 and
using the code big mood 9 that really is
makes me hungry just thinking about it
oh good I have it at home right now I'm
go home and cook that [ __ ] yeah yeah
that is my dinner tonight no know who
another adjective for you pose is a
snack oh yeah with like three cakes what
is they okay
oh you know you were in the middle of
saying you're not really a high energy
person which I mean I guess I don't feel
like I am I'm like a like I feel like
everyone thinks that I'm like this big
like pall of energy like always energy
energy all the time I am I'm very
balanced between extroverted and
introverted
but I tend to I need a lot of alone time
I need a lot of recharging time and I
grew up most of my life by myself I've
always been like very independent like
only child's like yeah no nothing and I
grew up latchkey kid basically a
latchkey kid he left home alone yeah so
like home after school yeah and mom was
doesn't come home until like 6:00 or so
and then when you don't have brothers or
sisters you kind of just learned how to
be by yourself and then as an adult you
need that alone time like you need it
you you grew up for 15 years
having 4 to 5 hours a day by yourself
and then as an adult you're not used to
not having that so that's why I have to
set my boundaries and really really
recharge like I have that totally like
made me realize something about myself
because I did grow up as a latchkey kid
but not for that long like when I was
really really little I was left alone a
lot but like that's why for me my recent
trip being completely alone made me feel
like oh my god I needed this and I never
realized that I actually needed that
alone time so you saying all that I'm
like whoa that's true it's really that's
really in me I threw at that yeah yeah I
think I didn't realize that about you
until we started spending more time
together but I can totally see it how
you're like I'm really not this super
high energy person but it's almost like
when you kind of know bosz like she's
just this like huge flame but then when
you know her more it's like there's
there's it's a lot deeper you're not
just this like oh my god I'm so funny
it's like branding first yeah in real
life and that's what I really wanted to
get out with this episode because like
there's it all of us being like in front
of camera and being in social media
there's like an image that we're all
portraying that we don't even maybe know
that we're portraying outwardly until
people like give us feedback like that
when yeah like in real life we could add
completely different or we could feel
completely
yeah yeah I think on camera we're all
kind of like heightened versions of
ourselves and then there's kind of this
weird stigma especially in the YouTube
world that you're not allowed to show
your bad side you can only show the good
of you so when we're heightening
ourselves up and we're only showing the
good side you don't really get our
medium you don't get our under that like
and I think that's kind of why we love
doing the show for so long because
talking candidly for an hour like you
really get to the meat of it we've
talked about a lot of like our pain yeah
things that we've been through how we
felt about them and I feel like you guys
know us a little bit more from watching
this then you probably have like after
watching like JK news or small for a
long time like it we-we-we bunch of
onion [ __ ] we got you say that -
because I coming from like the comedy
world I started off with a lot of
self-deprecating humor like darkness Sat
like sad humor and I felt like I could
never show my happy side or like be
cheesy or like I have a huge like
sentimental side that I like felt like
in social media I couldn't ever be like
open and vulnerable with because I my
image was more sarcastic and like dark
humored which I still AM but like you
know that that like image wanted to be
wanted to have more depth
yeah the sad sad girl because turns out
humans are complex and they have
different sides too though but here we
go a big word for you just nurture in
nurturing cats you and us like you your
plants all of love you know we are
amazing to me like if anyone ever hurt
you I'll break them Scary Spice a my
word for Nikki is probably like if it's
weird right
[ __ ] I'd say my word for Nikki is
probably like independent oh yeah
because when learning a lot more about
her background like how she was
waitressing and she really wanted to
like be an actor like nobody nobody
helped Nikki nobody held Nikki's hand
Nikki just said that's what I want I'm
walking there you know if anyone wants
to join me like I'll be here you know
but my god I thought you were crying but
I mean yeah and she's she all of her
businesses she owns like why I know you
have a joint now it's Eve but I mean for
the most part everything you done has
been you know single-handed but also
you're in the business they have
together Nikki basically does everything
and Steve just shows up yeah he's been
stepping up a lot so wild like I mean
yeah she does all that but I'm so easily
impressed she built a bed by herself I
just watched you on Instagram stories
and I just got tired I'm so proud but
Danny looks tiring but like you edit
your videos by yourself like I'd never
for sure what's a word for someone who
has so many hobbies yeah you're good at
to it's like I think or maybe it's
skills but I think similarly it's a
virtuoso you're very well-rounded you're
very very very well-rounded and I mean
like that's a good thing like because
with me like I have areas where there's
like a really big spike but then I have
some where it's like completely down and
like you are you're very well-rounded
that's so funny that you say that
because I always wished I had more of a
spike because I felt like my focus was
so skewed and I always saw you know how
there's two sides to every adjective the
negative one is jack-of-all-trades and I
always felt like I was jack of all
trades master of none and like I wish
that there was just one that I could
just like skyrocket at but I had so many
interests in everything that I was like
mean I think you're really amazing like
I like hosting and speaking in
bullet journaling yeah early everything
your plant life pretty life your your
your what else like you have so many
girls and I hate to like I feel like
when you see jack-of-all-trades it I
don't think that applies to you because
jack-of-all-trades is like somebody that
goes in and just picks up a few things
and they know a little bit of their feet
in it I feel like you're you're kind of
negative word is perfectionistic when it
comes to your skills and your hobbies
what happens as Nikki comes in and she's
like all right I want to do this and she
learns how to do it and she says okay
I'm really good at this now I'm gonna go
learn something else so instead of being
a jack-of-all-trades it has just a
little bit of everything your meter and
each thing you're good at is like a
hundred mastering everything don't feel
that way but thank you so much I have a
word for you it's definitely emotional
but not it's not yeah so like Nikki's
the first to wear a heart on her sleeve
she's the first to like let us know
she's like emotionally hurting right now
or if she's super happy like we're gonna
feel her energy like so definitely a
hundred percent if you're around Nikki
you got it you got to have good energy
because she's gonna suck it up and I
will be right for you yeah I will go
into the chat and I'm just like guys Oh
what is this that I'm feeling I don't
understand this I think it's like Gina
listen to me this is the word you're
feeling yeah this is how you do it get
some sage and put did you charge your
moon rock strip you put them in salt
water no that one goes here sunlight
like only the first of the fifteenth of
the month you're our go-to for those
astrology [ __ ] like is every retrograde
yet like it was out of it all the time
but then now I'm like Nikki yeah I think
about can I make this huge financial
decision or not she's like no you need
to wait
well the 24 I like when I'm like
communicated to Nicky before like what
like what my feelings were all I said
was Nicky I'm an Aquarius with a moon in
Aquarius it was like holy [ __ ] that
makes we actually make our business
decisions on mercury Gatorade time to
launch this show there's no mercury
Gator is very fair like you're so good
at being able to see both sides of every
situation and interpreting what's
happening you're getting good at that
thank you you know what's right and
you're just she's our warrior - she's
fought in some other business decisions
that we've had and she's she's got our
backs yeah yeah she's about you yeah
very loyal oh that's a big boy yeah you
proved that you don't have to be loud
and center of attention yeah be an alpha
in the room yeah that's what makes her
and true elf exactly she says Nicki's a
true alpha you will sit there and secret
like you will sit there and like you
just take it all in but you know that
you are what you are and nobody could
change that and I love that about you
I do what I can to make her cry it's not
working no yeah I was always earlier
when Jess said emotional she's gotta say
it was emotional
yeah oh yeah miss how do you feel
misunderstood um well I actually only
recently felt this way was like through
being on other people's videos because I
feel like in my own stuff I put out
exactly like what I feel I am and I'm
like a good representation of that but
um you know like being in other people's
videos people will say that I'm like
like dominating or anything like that
and I really don't feel dominating I
always feel like I want to include
people so that was like one that was
surprising to me this past year and then
yeah I used to get like I guess typecast
as like ditzy a lot which I say some
stupid [ __ ] actually that was not a
misconception like a complete office
you're so intelligent and you're so
introspective that's like silly
you know I feel like a fool or whatever
cuz like I know ditzy I know there's a
girl I know that's like the biggest ditz
ever she'll walk straight into a wall
and not understand gravity and all right
this episode I could [ __ ] talk
forever on but we need to move on to our
last final Gina darling everyone's
favorite younger brother
Gina darl America's hottest younger
brother oh yeah I like that yeah okay
well like us or like spikes like you
have horns like hear hear hear hear
I got a word for Gina my word is
carefree yeah it's like something that
like I feel like I really admire in you
because like there are some times where
like you know you get some hardships and
like you'll be like oh [ __ ] guys this is
happening but for the most part it just
slides right off patina I was I I don't
know and I remember you were talking
about kind of how you were raised how
your family kind of taught you like
they're they're they aren't [ __ ] you
are feeding you so like it doesn't
matter you know but I feel like I feel
like
a lot of the the shots that the world
throws at Gina mm-hmm nothing I feel
like you're strong you're so [ __ ]
strong I'm always continually impressed
by just like you I just see you as like
the strong tower this like um like like
fiery yeah you're just so like you built
this when I look at Gina online I'm like
she built this Empire I just like in a
castle and you're like on the top tier
that Terrace and you're just like
shouting orders I see like lightning
bolts very stupidly tiny but you know
one can [ __ ] with Gina like that do you
like your you're scary but in a good way
yeah yeah the person we want on our team
good is what I call edginess do you know
the person that like when you're like at
the bar and some guys trying to get all
on You Gina would be like sir what are
we doing here what's the goal let me see
your bank where all kind of heightened
versions of ourselves no this is really
who Gina is like I mean her whole like
branding is Gina there is no brand it's
Gina what I like I feel like and I don't
know if this is a hundred percent true
but this is kind of how I see you is
that like you really just don't let [ __ ]
get to you like hardly at all and I wish
that I could be a little bit more like
that because you're just like if it's
really not that's an issue you just
really don't give a [ __ ] I'm like yeah
you and you like you never let go of
that you're like nah I'm [ __ ] I'm this
yours oh good I'd like bouncing back and
like whatever is thrown at you it's like
oh no no no get back ten times worse
[ __ ] and it's but it doesn't even come
from a place of like it bothered you to
the point where you need to retaliate
it's just like oh this is fun for me
because how you tried it like not that
like it's like not that insecure like oh
I have to bring you back it's just like
oh [ __ ] that's cute yeah for those of
you who are wondering she is a Leo and
very much so very much you're so extra
but also in like the best
way possible and like your my goals I
picture you when I picture Gina it's
like she manifests like muscley tan boys
carrying her on a bed and she's eating
grapes but then she wakes up in the
morning on that bed of clouds and it's
smothered with like they're carrying her
in this big thing and it's like a box
with like curtains on it and it looks so
luxurious inside there's hot cheetos and
again i feel like that's true like I've
always I was never able to describe
myself what I am it's just like there's
a side of like all gold and beautiful
and sparkly yeah and you're like you're
like a like a wand like a crystal wand
but then like dipped in Crisco I make
good Lube you're like when like a
boyfriend tried to like hide the wedding
ring in a pizza out of grease do you
know what's the thing that people
misunderstand about you um
so I'm a firm believer and um how do I
put this
don't ever let them see you sweat when
you're working hard yeah totally see
that yeah so a lot of people are like
well what does she do all day she just
sits around play games I'm like well
that's what I put out you know I put
actually yeah that topic came up
recently with a friend of mine he's like
you you never really let people see you
sweat I'm like no not really cuz you
know they don't need to I like I am
really chill but behind the scenes like
I love working yeah I do I truly do like
business and stuff like that it really
gets me going you know
but I am a firm believer in enjoying
life yes just like enjoying everything
that you have you know because we spoke
about this before I believe in the
bigger picture when I have my hardships
I will always remember like I'm lucky to
even be here to experience all this and
a part of that is just not letting
people you know gets you so a lot of
people are just like well she's just
like this ditzy blonde asian girl that's
never done anything that's probably had
dudes pay for everything is that people
think you're just like big ass like the
men that she's around or not around I've
literally never seen also like a kind of
misconception that like I don't I guess
I feel like the public could see is that
like Gina's always like glammed-out you
know she's got her [ __ ] Chanel or her
Gucci I don't know it's hip with the
kids right now what I was pleasantly
surprised to find the like Gina is not
just flexing on the masses Gina's very
good with her money and she only buys
things like that like if she's got it
comfortably like the [ __ ] is saving
saving saving saving she's very
financially astute she doesn't look
financially literate but she's not into
you yeah and you a lot of you probably
think she is no she is like she is
killing it she's really killing it and
one thing I said recently is that you're
so clear with your branding and what you
just said of like not see it letting
people see you sweat I feel like that is
such a clear like that's what you put
out in the world like all of us are
inspired by your way that you just let
things slide like brush and you brush it
off you just keep your head up and you
see all the good in everything and I
think that is so like important and
that's such a cool thing that you bring
to the group and to the chat cuz she'll
like [ __ ] go in on someone in the
chat and then like be filled with
rainbows
yeah it's agressive love is what I have
yeah like I I got very um what is it
very protective of you guys yeah
I mean so like I'm not ashamed to go to
your comments you just talk a [ __ ] ton
of [ __ ] Gina back sometimes right yeah
she's got friend they were like Gina you
don't have to make a video person I feel
like so this was so long ago but one of
my first interactions with Gina that I
remember thinking like oh my god I
thought I kind of like understood her
like vibe but I totally didn't get it
was that I was kind of scoffing at a
room that was like clapping at something
like really heartfelt and cute and I was
like this is so [ __ ] cheesy and
Gina's like shut up
don't you love happiness and I was like
oh she's a roasted me like literally to
my face yeah I should be happy like
everyone's happy you know like I never
would have expected Gina to do something
like that but when she did I was like
okay I kind of get it like she just
wants to enjoy life and like the people
around her to enjoy life and we all know
you love pleasurable spanking stress all
right well guys let us know in the
comments what your first impressions of
everybody has you wanted to say that I'm
like we need to make a whole video about
our first impressions of each other Gary
spice got Mason spikes on Karen spice
thanks for watching so you're like three
Spice Girls a spice for the rest of us
you're definitely not sporty spice
though in any way that's right I look
like I'm like I am asleep a lot of times
what I'm awake I'm awake I'm awake but
I'm here to protect you guys no matter
what
we love you for that all right I know
who else is protecting us as sponsors
yeah I'm like one who's pregnant it's
pregnant nothing yet
so hellofresh you know if you go to
hellofresh calm slash big mood 9 and use
the code big mood 9 you get 9 free meals
so definitely check that out
function a beauty you can get 20% off
your first shampoo and conditioner set
head to function of beauty calm / big
mood and take the hair quiz and you get
20% off of your custom formula and third
love you there's a freaking perfect bra
out there for you and if you have not
experienced it yet you really should go
take their fit quiz and go to 3rd love
comm / big mood to find your perfect
fitting and get 15% off your first
purchase that's third love claw the
third love comm / big mood for 15% off
thank you so much for coming to our
first tell us oh yeah yeah put that mood
in there boy